So now you have a few more tools
to approach problems in your code.
But this is just the beginning.
When you really get into it,
debugging isn't just correcting errors,
or even just figuring out
how you made a mistake.
It's a scientific process
of examining code
to discover things you
didn't expect in it.
Debugging is a really important
skill to learn if you want to do
software engineering.
In real-world computing systems,
bugs cause problems that
are a lot bigger than just
getting a weird error on your screen.
Correctly locating errors is a big
part of writing reliable software.
In fact, we have a whole course on
a scientific approach to debugging.
After you've finished
your current projects,
you might want to take
a look at that next.